thank you
[Music]
Hamza dawood a student at Stanford
University has vowed I'm going to
physically fight zionists next year if
someone comes at me with that Israel is
a democracy and after I abolish
your ass I'll go ahead and work every
day for the rest of my life to abolish
your petty ass ethno supremacist settler
colonial state
when I spoke at Stanford last year there
was a great deal of leftist Hysteria and
fear-mongering in the run-up to the
event a clack of professors actually
wrote a warning about Robert Spencer and
his islamophobic incitements to violence
as these Liars probably knew the only
real threat of violence was to me and to
those students who were courageous
enough to support my appearing on campus
confirming that now is the illustrious
Hamza daud who whined him probably amid
the hysteria about my appearance on
campus that he had been questioned about
my position at Stanford because of my
religion yeah sure Hamza everyone knows
Stanford is a hotbed of islamophobia
anyway dawood who is not surprisingly at
the Jihad abetting United Nations
Refugee agency the unhcr has now
confirmed who the violent thugs really
are the Fearless Peerless Stanford
College Republicans issued a statement
pointing out what everyone at Stanford
should know threatening to assault other
students who hold a different point of
view is anathema to a free society and
any kind of education let alone the
operation of the Premier Research
University in the world
amid the Uproar over my appearance at
Stanford and the Planned disruption of
my event by administrators and students
I noted that it endeavoring to make sure
that as few people as possible heard me
and in relentlessly defaming me in the
student press before the event Stanford
administrators faculty and students were
behaving like fascists in the coming of
the Third Reich historian Richard J
Evans explains how in the early days of
National Socialist Germany Stormtroopers
Brown Shirts organized campaigns against
unwanted professors in the local
newspapers and staged Mass disruptions
of their lectures to express dissent
from Nazi positions became a matter of
taking one's life into one's hands the
idea of people of opposing viewpoints
airing their disagreements in a civil
and mutually respectful manner was gone
one was a Nazi or one was silent and
fearful
the Stanford fascists in question when
they took notice of this charge at all
ridiculed it but here Hamza dawood has
once again demonstrated that it is true
and made the analogy between the
Stanford leftist establishment and
fascism even more exact by adding in a
heavy dose of Jew hatred while Hamza
dawood be expelled from Stanford will he
be fired from the unhcr are you kidding
he represents everything that both
entities want and are working hard to
inculcate into as many people as
possible a propensity for violence
hatred of Jews and Israel arrogance
self-righteousness and an aggrieved
sense of victimhood
Stanford has a massive problem today
with Fascism and the forcible
suppression of dissenting views now with
the threat of violence but its
administrators who doubt this whole
views practically identical to those of
Hamza daoud will no doubt do nothing but
Aid in a bet the growth of fascism on
campus by continuing to encourage the
likes of hanza daud and the spurious
pose of a grieved victimhood that he has
callow as he is already mastered the
problem you see is not Jihad mass murder
nor is it the institutionalized
oppression of women gays and others
under Sharia nor is it the Palestinians
who pass out candies and hold
celebrations over the wanton Massacre of
Israeli civilians no none of those are
problems at all and the demonization and
suppression of views that aren't hard
left on campus that merits no notice
whatsoever no the real problems today
are islamophobia Zionism American
imperialism racism and the rest Stanford
and other universities and colleges are
busy all over the country indoctrinating
a gen generation of Hamza dodes when
these programmed Bots inclined to
violence and both incapable and
contemptuous of rational thought are let
loose on American society watch out
I'm Robert Spencer a Shulman fellow for
the David harwood's Freedom Center and
director of jihad watch this video has
been brought to you by the center for
security policy
[Music]